en el último vídeo nos quedamos
analizando el problema número 13 de la
sección número 7 del examen número 5 y
decía más o menos así tenemos un candado
con tres números de dos dígitos a esos
importantes le voy a poner aquí tenemos
un candado y tiene tres números tres
números de dos dígitos dígitos y de
hecho todas las opciones que me dan
tienen precisamente tres números de dos
dígitos ok ahora me dicen que la
combinación del candado debe de cumplir
los siguientes criterios uno de los
números debe tener impar otro de los
números debe de ser múltiplos de cinco y
otro de los números debe ser el día en
que cumple años carlos de hecho carlos
era el dueño del candado y habíamos
dicho que bueno carlos puede cumplir
años en algún día entre el primero y el
31 de algún mes ok
hasta ahí y vamos bien
ahora lo que nos dicen después es que
cada uno de los números tienen que
cumplir solo uno de estos criterios y de
hecho en el vídeo pasado me confundió un
poco y me puse nervioso porque olvide
que solamente se tienen que cumplir uno
de los criterios por cada uno de los
números entonces eso lo voy a apuntar
cada número cada
número número debe cumplir debe cumplir
sólo uno de estos criterios solo
de estos criterios ok y aquí tengo mis
tres criterios que ya te he mencionado
criterios ok lo que me preguntan en este
problema número trece es cuál podría ser
y eso también es muy importante cuál
podría ser una combinación que abra este
candado entonces lo voy a poner aquí lo
que buscamos es tres números de dos
dígitos que puedan ser que podría ser
podría ser no forzosamente es pero lo
que buscamos es uno que podría ser una
combinación que habla este candado ok y
vamos a apuntar de una vez todos mis
incisos el inciso am me dice 14 20 y 13
ok el inciso b me dice 14 25 y 13 ok de
hecho en el vídeo pasado tuve una
confusión con estos dos pero vamos a ver
qué me dicen los demás
el inciso se me dice 15 18 y 16 15 18 y
16 a veces de él insistió tm dice 20 15
y 20 ok y por último el inciso en me
dice 34 34 30 y 21 y 21 ok entonces
vamos a ver cuál de estos incisos es mi
respuesta y necesito que cada uno de
estos números cumpla solamente uno de
estos criterios y los criterios son que
uno de los números deba de ser impar
sólo uno de los números debe de ser
impar uno de los números sean múltiplo
de cinco y otro sea un posible día del
cumpleaños de carlos ok cuáles de estos
incisos puedo cancelar de una manera muy
rápida bueno creo que el inciso b lo
podemos cancelar de una manera muy
rápida porque tiene dos números que son
impares ahora lo voy a dejar aquí le voy
a poner un pequeño asterisco porque
justo con estos dos tuve
problema en el vídeo pasado así que
ahorita cancelamos al inciso 20 vamos a
ver qué pasa con el inciso c en el
inciso se tienen los números 15 18 y 16
y si nos fijamos en el primer criterio
uno de ellos debe de ser impar como
solamente tenemos un número impar voy a
tomarme al 15 con mi número impar
pero después me dice uno de ellos debe
de ser un múltiplo de 5 y de estos 3 el
único que es múltiplo de 5 es 15 otra
vez por lo tanto el 15 cumple dos
criterios y quedamos que cada número
debe de cumplir sólo uno de estos
criterios por lo tanto podemos cancelar
de una manera muy rápida el inciso c el
inciso sea no es nuestra respuesta ahora
qué pasa con el ejercicio de él insistió
de creo que lo podemos cancelar una
manera muy rápida porque tienen 20 y 20
tenemos 220 sí por lo tanto si uno de
estos criterios los cumple el número 20
este de aquí también va a poder cumplir
el otro criterio que cumpla el otro 20
fíjate bien necesitamos un número impar
aquí tenemos un número impar entonces lo
agarramos
busco un número que sea múltiplo de 5
pero en este caso tengo dos números los
220 es que son múltiplos de 5 uno de
estos números debe de ser múltiples 5 y
tenemos 220 es posibles que cumplen este
criterio por lo tanto esta no es mi
solución estos 220 pueden confundirte
bastante vamos a ver el inciso en el
inciso e dice tengo un número en par ok
tomemos el mi número impar que es el 21
déjenme agarrar el color rojo ok
después tengo un número de ellos que
tienen que ser un múltiplo de 5 el 30 es
multi 35 así que vamos a tomarlo el 30
cumple que es múltiplo de 5 no es impar
por lo tanto parece ser que vamos bien
pero si el 30 es múltiplo de 5 entonces
no me queda de otra el 34 tendría que
cumplir que es uno de los números que
podrían ser el día del cumpleaños de
carlos pero aquí yo tengo una confusión
carlos no puede cumplir un día 34 estás
de acuerdo
ninguno de los meses del año tiene 34
días por lo tanto ya no puede ser éste
y bueno vamos a fijarnos en estos dos el
inciso a el inciso a de nuestra
respuesta correcta porque porque yo
tengo aquí a un número impar el 13 es
número en pares y entonces lo atrapó y
digo que este 13 cumple mi primera
opción ok y solamente cumple esta es un
número impar no es múltiplo de 5 y
podría ser uno de los días del
cumpleaños de carlos pero vamos a ver si
es posible que con nosotros cumplamos
esta tercera condición uno de los
números es múltiplo de cinco de los que
me quedan y de hecho de los tres el
único que es múltiplo de cinco es 20 por
lo tanto voy a decir que el 20 se cumpla
la propiedad número 2 el 20 me va a
cumplir la propiedad de que es el número
que es múltiplo de 5 14 19 y 13 no lo es
20 no es impar entonces vamos bien y
bueno 20 podrá ser el día del cumpleaños
de carlos sin embargo vamos a ver si el
14 lo puede ser y bueno de hecho el 14
si lo puede ser el 14 puede ser un día
del cumpleaños de carlos porque es un
número que está entre 1 y 31
por lo tanto aquí tengo un inciso que
tiene a tres números de dos dígitos que
cumplen estas tres propiedades y no se
cruzan entre ellos estamos hablando de
que éste podría ser podría ser la
combinación del candado de carlos puede
ser que no lo sean pero al menos sabemos
que cumple estos tres criterios ok
entonces vamos a fijarnos en enciso ven
y nosotros dijimos que el inciso b no
nos sirve porque tiene dos números
impares si nosotros empezamos con este
como si fuera un número impar este mi
número impar entonces 25 también es un
número impar y necesitamos que cada
número cumpla solamente uno de sus
criterios y aquí tengo dos números que
son impares y por lo tanto el inciso b
no puede ser porque tengo dos números
que cumplen un criterio uno de los
números es impar espero que con esta
ayuda y con esta idea entiendas mucho
mejor el problema número 13 y pues bueno
ya lo resolvimos en dos vídeos vamos a
intentar hacer el problema número 14 así
que empecemos por aquí
número 14 dicen cuál es una expresión
equivalente para la raíz de x + 9 esto
es igual a x menos 3 y yo nos dicen que
x sea mayor que 3 y nos piden una
expresión equivalente para esto bueno
aquí tengo una ecuación pero como
encontramos una expresión equivalente lo
que se me ocurre es que voy a quitar
esta raíz cuadrada de este lado de la
ecuación y la voy a quitar se elevó a
ambos lados de esta ecuación al cuadrado
este lado al cuadrado y este otro lado
al cuadrado ok de tal manera que la raíz
cuadrada se vaya con este cuadrado y me
va a quedar solamente que x + 9 que x +
9 es lo mismo que este binomio al
cuadrado perfecto y como elevamos un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto pues bueno
tenemos que elevar el primer término al
cuadrado x cuadrada después a esto
sumarle dos veces el primero por el
segundo 2 por x 2 x x menos 3 me da
6x ya esto sumarle el cuadrado del
segundo término menos 3 al cuadrado es 9
ok ahora si no te acuerdas de cómo
elevar un binomio al cuadrado perfecto
recuerda que esto es lo mismo que x
menos 3 que x 3 por x menos 3 tal vez
así se te facilite más obtener la
expresión equivalente a este binomio
cuadrado perfecto ahora yo aquí tengo un
9 sumando y aquí tengo otro 9 sumando si
yo restó un 9 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación este 9 con este 9 se va a ir y
solamente me va a quedar que x es igual
a x cuadrada menos 6x que por cierto ya
es uno de nuestros incisos este es el
inciso c y ya que está mi solución x es
igual a es cuadrada menos 6x y bueno nos
piden que x sea mayor que 3 porque se
están fijando en la raíz cuadrada lo que
no quieren es que la raíz cuadrada de
números negativos ni que esta expresión
se haga cero en fin ya tengo aquí el
problema número 14 y ahora vamos a
trabajar con el problema número 15 el
problema número 15 que dice cuántos
enteros en el conjunto
entre 1 y 100 no son el cuadrado de un
número entero ok si yo tengo un conjunto
el conjunto de números uno dos tres y
así me dijo y me sigo y me sigo hasta
llegar al 99 y al 100 tengo aquí a los
100 primeros números naturales ok
cuántos de estos no son un cuadrado
perfecto de algún número entero bueno
pues pensemos en los cuadrados perfectos
de algunos números enteros si yo tengo
por ejemplo aquí lo voy a poner al 1 al
1 cuando lo elevó al cuadrado me da 1 ok
al 2 cuando lo elevó al cuadrado me da 4
al 3 cuando le llevó al cuadrado me da 9
al 4 cuando lo elevó al cuadrado me da
16 al 5 cuando lo llevo al cuadrado me
da 25 al 6 me da 36 ok al 7 me da 49
8 64 al 9 me dan 81 al 10 me da 100 y
siguió elevo ahora al cuadrado 11 qué
creés 11 al cuadrado 11 el cuadrado es
lo mismo que 121 y 121 no es un número
que está en este conjunto por lo tanto
los únicos que me importa elevado al
cuadrado son los números del 1 al 10
porque esos cuadrados si están en este
conjunto entonces a partir del 11 en
adelante ningún número elevado al
cuadrado va a caer en este conjunto
ahora date cuenta que el 1 fue el 1 lo
podemos quitar de aquí el 2 fue el 4 lo
podemos quitar de aquí el 39 lo podemos
quitar de aquí cuántos números estoy
quitando bueno pues estoy quitando 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 es decir sólo 10 números
son cuadrados perfectos en este conjunto
que tengo aquí de lujo por lo tanto si
solamente 10 números son cuadrados
perfectos de este conjunto que tengo
aquí pues cuántos me sobran
pues la cantidad de números que tengo
aquí son 100 la cardinal ida de este
conjunto son 100 pero si de estos 100 10
de ellos son cuadrados perfectos
entonces 90 números 90 números no son
cuadrados perfectos de ningún número
entero y esa es mi respuesta 90 la cual
es el inciso e ok ya no tengo tiempo
seguimos en el siguiente vídeo